[Music]
hey everybody welcome to every damn day
I'm Ryan Beck I'm here with Ron Funches
today and we're gonna be chatting but
first make sure to check out Ron's
special Ron Funches giggle fit on
January 4th on Comedy Central so you're
I'm a big wrestling fan you're a big
wrestling fan yeah and you got to meet
Ric Flair is that right were you
terrified I was very terrified because
he is a legend he could take your
girlfriend even if she's not with you
even at like 80 order yeah Oh
surprisingly yes
he did we would together but like you
did that as for the special did he woo
like off oh yeah he was all that he was
all the time it's just what he does he's
a legend enjoy life he's done so much he
looks so great now he's so old and he's
full of so much alcohol and sex yeah
it's true I saw a headline the other day
that said Ric Flair is still drinking
it's like that should not be in the news
but yeah if he was healthy he would
still be wrestling yeah that's true
you wrestle you didn't you like found
that you can use it in your everyday
life not at all no it like like fighting
for a parking spaces no because the only
thing I would know is how to like just
fall and get hurt I could get them oh
you can take the bump yeah yeah but
that's it I'm not gonna be like for like
an insurance claim you can like roll
over a car or something oh yeah I got
several plans for that yeah every time
in college cuz they said if you get hit
by a car and on campus that you would
get like free tuition and I don't know
if maybe this is just what I said that
to you everybody at the University of
Missouri that in the so you'd always
walk in the crosswalk but like Darden in
front of the cars people were pranking
you
they might be right yeah I think you
have bad friend well yeah what is it
what is it like to Train like what do
you do you do a lot of squats you do a
lot of squats and you get hit in the
head with folding chairs a lot does it
hurt
he does but he really hit you with the
chair they really hit you with
everything and then what it usually is
is like a trained wrestler who's
actually really good I was trained by a
guy named Tyler Bateman and also another
gentleman named Brody Kings is really
good and Brody his whole thing was just
like coming here and I'm just gonna chop
your chest until I'm bored and then
leave just marks on you right and you're
just like red and raw like he's just
laughing he's laughing having a good did
you like him mmm
I mean it was like a beautiful
relationship how far into the
relationship until he started chopping
you its third day third day okay so
today was three hundred squats which is
a lot of squats that is a lot of squats
that'll help you when you're like
elderly though no no but that's what
they say they say that when you're for
elderly people like the best thing you
can do to get out of chairs and stuff is
work on your legs yeah but now I feel
like they're just shot I had to live in
my bathtub for like a whole day you see
yeah I mean you're a very nice person if
you like very positive what about
wrestling is appealing Oh cuz it's you
know it so many not this actually is but
I love it from the for the deeper things
you can be like oh the pageantry the
attacking and stuff but I love it that
everybody's all in on it together
you know that's what I like I like that
they're after the shows they're all
friends and they're hanging out I like
independent wrestling which is really
big right now like new Japan's Ring of
Honor yeah Pro Wrestling guerrilla like
that where I can like cheer for these
people you see families you see drunk
idiots you see everybody out there
cheering and then you you get to meet
the wrestlers I'm smoking weed with the
wrestlers after the show you can't do
that at regular events so I
you don't go to like a hockey game and
then everyone's yeah Mario Lemieux which
is the only hockey player I know and I
couldn't even pronounce his name right
Ron the internet loves lists so I was
hoping that we could come up with a list
of six reasons why wrestling is the best
reality show Oh easy yeah okay number
one feather boas there's a lot of
feather boas number two everybody's wet
mm-hmm boom hair wet all the all the
time all the time I understand that how
could you hate a spray you down in class
do they spray you down in number three
the outfits are amazing everybody's
wearing something skin tight it's
enjoyable
no matter your gender or sexual
preference there's something to look at
yeah it's like a tough roller disco
number four the music I went to
SummerSlam and I was like so excited for
the show and and everything but like I
found that nothing got me more amped up
than when just people would come out and
I just wanted everyone to just come out
they could have done like a fashion show
my special is like a wrestling intern to
me there's nothing better than a
wrestling it really sets the tone like
when I perform on on the road often I
come out to Stone Cold Steve Austin you
hear the glass break you know somebody's
about to get their ass kicked
do you find that people are then
disappointed that you're not stone cold
well it's a great position so wait what
number are we on I think we're at five
five Oh your five you're on five oh I'm
on five panting I love just any change
yeah like where can you do that outside
of a cult-like establishment were you
just chanting with your friends all day
Chan whatever you want like we chant
things like friendship sportsmanship
things you can't say
be able to send them here but you can TV
they over dumped it but I love chanting
number six we need a six one number six
is just smoking we were reps that's it
that's the six reasons why wrestling is
the best reality show it's the only
interactive reality show yeah you get
right in there with a partner yeah you
gotta like call the number or vote why
why vote will you could toke right the
voice wants you to text you're not
smoking weed with the Real Housewives
like nothing's going nothing good well
that's number seven Ron thank you for
joining us today
make sure to check out runs special
January 4th Ron Funches giggle fit on
Comedy Central
one of my favorite activities recently
is just like staring at women and winter
coats
and just wondering like what's under
there and I know I know a lot of dudes
like bikinis but I'm a weirdo como let
me use my imagination this is a fun game
it doesn't bother anybody it's not too
creepy little creepy but I still
recommend it to anybody
I call it hidden figures oh yeah you had
this card the whole time what this
Carlos Mencia DVD I mean to be honest I
kind of want to dr. Katz's one but I'll
take the cool guy you come to several of
my shows and didn't do the jokes about
his autistic children that season four
for you so
[Music]